the White House is apparently furious
that Russia trolled them in the Oval
Office
just on Wednesday right the day after
Donald Trump fired FBI director James
Comey Donald Trump held a somewhat
secretive meeting in the Oval Office
with the Russian Foreign Minister Sergey
Lavrov and Russia's ambassador to the
u.s. Sergei kiss' lyac now if those
names sounds familiar to you
they should and that's why the optics of
the meeting are a disaster I'll get into
the specifics in a second but the optics
are a disaster
the day after firing the person in
charge of the FBI's investigation into
Donald Trump's connections to Russia you
invite to the White House some of the
Russians specifically involved in the
undisclosed meetings of your own White
House's staff so that's really really
sketchy but then they have this meeting
and the White House doesn't allow
American reporters in the Oval Office to
cover the meeting before the meeting or
after the meeting but Russian media is
allowed to cover the meeting this was
the day after Trump fired Comey like I
said one of the people at the meeting is
Russian ambassador Sergey kis lyac whose
meetings with Trump's surrogates are
part of the investigation that's taking
place
kiss Lee AK met with Jeff Sessions met
with campaign adviser Carter page met
with disgraced and shamed former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
met with Trump's son-in-law and current
adviser Jared Kushner multiple officials
from the US intelligence community
community have said that Sergey kis lyac
is widely considered to be a spy so the
White House invites him to the Oval
Office
Sergey kis lyac ignores security
concerns of inviting a widely suspected
Russian spy into the Oval Office but
then only allows Russian media to cover
the meeting I'm saying this facetiously
but maybe we should start trusting the
White House a little more they clearly
don't care about looking corrupt because
the day after firing James Comey they
have Russia suspected Russian spies in
the Oval
office and only allow Russian media to
photograph it maybe there's nothing to
see there because they clearly aren't
trying to cover up the obvious sketchy
activities not only did the White House
refused to let American media cover this
meeting between Donald Trump and top
Russian officials the White House became
enraged when state media from Russia who
were invited started publishing the
pictures that they took of the meeting
let's take a look at first a tweet here
where you will see the pictures
published this is one of the pictures
that was taken in the Oval Office Donald
Trump I believe that Sergey Lavrov there
and then an anonymous White House
official is quoted as having saying they
tricked us that's the problem with the
Russians they lie the American press was
allowed to photograph Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson and Russian Foreign
Minister Sergey Lavrov after their
meeting and Russian state media proudly
tweeted a video of Lavrov being
condescending and sarcastic to the
American press about commis firing
here's the tweet where Sergey Lavrov was
FBI director James Comey fired you're
kidding pretending not to have heard of
that here is the video of that take a
look and a listen to this yep so this is
like last month when Lavrov started
talking down to NBC News correspondent
Andrea Mitchell saying where are your
manners who raised you et cetera it is
so obvious that Russian government
officials are just cocky and dismissive
towards the press and don't take them
seriously because the totally corrupt
Russian government isn't held
accountable by the press in the way that
the US government is held accountable
and it's sort of rubbing off I guess I
would say on the Trump
raishin they've adopted many of the same
Russian attitudes and tactics when it
comes to dealing with the press making
it harder for people to contact the
White House we've covered that refusing
to answer questions at press briefings
I've told you about Sean Spicer
leaving a press briefing without taking
any questions calling news outlets they
don't like fake news not inviting
American press to important meetings
like this one in the Oval Office it's
rubbing off on the White House and it is
very very scary